was this movie sort of In Your Eyes the
close to a very turbulent and sometimes
highlight packed chapter in the DC
history I think the box office kind of
made at the end uh I think that if
people wanted the continuation of this
universe uh they should have gone to it
because I think that it could have
continued or it could have closed and I
think this closed it
hello everyone and welcome to after show
my name is Mark Ellis and today's
episode is all about the flash gonna do
a deep dive into the details of the
movie answer some of the burning
questions that it left and as always
we're talking spoilers so if you've not
yet seen the flash make sure you check
it out and then come on back here and
join me and koi johndro our special
guest today who loves all things flash
Loves All Things comic books this young
man on any given week at his local comic
book store has upwards of 75 different
issues that you're getting yeah I read
between 68 and now 77 Comics a week uh
so that puts me in the about 300 Comics
a month range which frankly is a bit
much even for the flash it's uh it's
beautiful I love it I'm happy but I see
the problem it's like when you go to
Vegas and you're like I got this I'm
winning yeah yeah you think about how
much money those issues cost and you
think about a credit card and your like
current limit is I know it's my job and
some of it's tax deductible but do I
have a problem should I call someone is
there a comment Anonymous well luckily
this is where all that knowledge gets
put to use because we're going to be
talking about the film and also there's
going to be a lot of spoiler territory
but before we get into any of that koi
I'm just curious because as we're
filming this we're seeing the box office
results come in yeah from the past
weekend it's opening weekend 55 million
dollars domestically maybe tack on
another 50 to 60 million worldwide what
was behind this performance or lack
thereof in your opinion I think it's the
perfect storm I think this is going to
be studied for years in a lab I think
that so many things went wrong at once I
think there's a combination between I
wouldn't consider it superhero fatigue I
would consider it like a shift in
expectation I don't think we have a
fatigue I think we now have a higher bar
I think that the superhero culture used
to rely on like what a novel idea a
comic book movie We're 15 years in 20
years in we should really acknowledge
that it's not a novelty anymore if a
movie's gonna do well it needs to be
quality as well as have certain other
expectations I would argue a lot of
people look look at comic book movies as
a lesser I think they have more to do
they have to be a good movie they also
have to appeal to a devout fandom they
have to appeal to the actual regular
demographic and they have to advertise
in a way that somehow spoils everything
and nothing I consider superhero movies
a more uh hard to accomplish task than
they were five years ago and I'd say
they're harder to accomplish now than a
low to mid budget film I think High
budget films are in their own problem
area right now because we're throwing
money at everything and the budgets are
getting too high but I think that a
quality mid-budget film is actually more
likely to profit now than a standard
comic book movie and so I think that we
have the fatigue adjacent problem but
about quality not just generalizing it I
think we have James Gunn and Peter
saffron taking over at a time where they
had to but the way they announced it put
people in a position of not knowing
expectations as a comic fan James Gunn
coming out and being like these Comics
are what we're adapting and showing a
loyalty and showing us is the best thing
to get my expectations up for two years
from now but the people that are Snyder
fans the people that are DC EU fans the
people that have been fans of the
material that's only on their screen
feel betrayed and then they feel like
why would I go support the thing that
isn't helping me even though inherently
those are the characters they want to
support like they it's a it's
contradiction they're like I'm mad at
this thing that is a love letter to my
thing because the movie is a love letter
to the thing and then on top of that
you've got the lack of press tour
because of the real life legal
ramifications of a lead actor you've got
the lack of ability to talk about the
movie to scale because if you've got one
actor filming a movie that is uh you
know in the Ben Affleck of it all you've
got another actor that doesn't do a lot
of press in general in Keaton so there's
two of your three leads right you've got
one actor that plays two parts that
isn't able to do press and then you've
got the the PowerHouse the movie for me
Sasha Kaye who's doing all the press
that is the least known so it's a
perfect storm of the one we don't know
that's great but you don't know they're
great yet is coming out to say they're
great in this thing that you don't know
is great I was gonna say as you're
describing all these different reasons
for the box office I'm thinking of that
wave in The Perfect Storm 100 you're the
boat and you're just you're trying to
make it over it tip of the wave the last
bit when you're describing a comic book
movie in general this seems to have have
a lot of the ingredients that you would
want in a modern one because before if
this was Batman 1989 this is Superman 78
even Iron Man in 2008 you can open a
movie big on a single superhero and have
them be the star but this had that team
up quality and boy did they sell it on
that premise where you could argue that
most folks who paid to see this movie
might have been going to see a Batman
most likely Michael Keaton's Batman in
addition to the to the fact that the
flash was actually the Title Character
right so let's get into the actual movie
itself overall you're walking out of the
theater and I just put a mic in your
face what are you saying about this
movie I had a very positive experience I
was so joyous I was so happy for me the
movie was what summer Blockbusters are
meant to be as is implies there are
things that are wrong but the way I want
to feel is how I left this movie I want
to have spectacle I want to have joy I
want to have heart my big problem with a
lot of superhero fodder is it becomes
fodder it becomes uh literally a do
these XYZ here you got a movie this
actually had heart on top of the XYZ
which is what I really want I felt for
his mom I felt for his Strife I felt for
the contradiction of the trolley problem
to this scale I thought it was a genius
way to make a hero the trolley problem
is a classic you know idea of morality
and they did it to a multiversal scale
do you save one mom or the Multiverse
and they made the guy kill his mom
so to me it had all the things and then
it had the spectacle of bringing back
Nostalgia it had a lot of visuals that
though everything didn't work for me
more did than didn't and it introduced
one of the hardest characters to
introduce in the comic books Cara is in
Kalel Shadow because she's the cousin of
Superman that's already hard now you've
got the real life oh my God thought in
the shadow of Henry Cavill during a
recast new actress that's from a soap
opera as far as I know the only thing
they've done and there is shining light
in this movie so I walked out going like
I just made a new star I got to see an
incredible acting toward a force of two
actors playing opposite each other in a
hero's journey like a a youngin hero's
journey opposite itself is so genius
because you've got the Arc of the
youngberry that reflects the early films
that a lot of people were like that's
not flash that's an annoying character
literally kind of being fan serviced to
be annoying you've got the more mature
Berry who's gone through his own Heroes
dream because the drama and Trauma of
losing his family educating himself on
what it's like to have to mature and
therefore you've got the comedy that
works twice over so every punch lands
twice I thought it all worked seeing the
berries sort of mature themselves as as
Elder body I call them Elder them
Elderberry but it's also it's like and
there's a lot of member berries in this
movie too so there's a lot of berries
going a lot of berries moving in the
flash as we said before 85 is the
audience score with a 66 percent Tomato
Meter which is still kind of fluctuating
as more reviews come in the critics can
census on Rotten Tomatoes is The Flash
is funny fittingly fast paced and
overall ranks as one of the best DC
movies in recent years so if you're
looking at this movie I thought the
pacing was tremendous yeah the own
ironically the the slowest this movie
got was when the Flash and we show flash
slowing down because Flash is so
incredibly fast that they could just do
all these things just like like putting
babies in microwaves
watching that that play out was so slow
yeah it was so weird that like I'm like
can we just speed this up a little the
guys I understand that it's the flash
swelling all this stuff down for us yeah
you can't experience how fast it is but
still I I don't mind if you if I'm not a
huge fan of kids I don't like seeing
babies in microwaves that was too long
like that's a long BB and you see a lot
of stuff with the visual effects and and
I'm just it's never gonna bother me that
much anymore because so my you know I I
we grew up in the era practical effects
and you see the CGI which was never
quite ready yeah match the filmmaker's
vision with very few exceptions and I
think that that's sort of the case here
but I think a lot of it once you get
into with with Barry running that fast
that he can literally turn time back
yeah and get into that Vortex I thought
actually that was more of an artistic
Choice than a visual effects one am I
wrong here animus Yeti has been very
public about choosing to film that way
and also adds the horror elements that
he he's most known for there's a bit of
an uncanny valley to his work where it's
like that uh that uncomfortability of a
visual so to me it makes more sense to
have a Vortex of time like this than
like a space hole which they even joked
about it there's those moments but like
what do you represent space time with it
worked for me I would have liked a
little bit more of a photorealistic
choice but it did feel like a choice so
it didn't bother me because I was like
oh it's a stylistic thing that wasn't
where the heart was the heart is in the
rest of the movie so I didn't mind that
if that was how things looked that
needed to be like oh no we've lost mom
that would have bothered me but since it
was in a very stylized literal Dome I
wasn't as affected emotionally and and
seeing the storyline you know you're
you're never going to be able to avoid
comparisons to how that Marvel's been
utilizing their Multiverse versus DC so
we'll get into that in a little bit but
but for right now let's just talk about
the Barry of it all yeah where I felt
like at times and Ezra Miller if you
separate art from artists and you're
just looking at this film and their
performance in it tremendous but two
berries on screen I'll say something
positive and I'll say something negative
it was a lot it was a lot to take that
sort of energy twice over can't imagine
to me but as a credit to both the
performance and the direction of the
film
it I I saw this movie at cinemacon it
was the first time I got to see it and
you know they they came out and they
said we're really excited it's not quite
finished and so we're looking at well
maybe is it the effects is it something
else but I it took me 30 minutes into
the film to realize oh my God I'm
watching two Ezra Millers yeah it was so
natural yeah the way that Ezra played
off himself that I had to like it is
this was not watching Van Damme play
twins in Double Impact no this was so
seamless that I forgot I was watching
One performer do two parts and a
director direct movie twice yeah that
was so incredible to me if you actually
break down what goes into this every
actor act to act off two people one of
which isn't there the director has to
direct a young Berry movie and an
Elderberry movie you've got to go
through this entire journey and it's not
like they don't affect each other it's
not like it's just dialogue these are
emotionally resonant moments that grow
both characters and then if you think
about the actual conclusion of the film
The Third Berry only works because of
the lessons the Elderberry taught
youngberry so the third Berry only exist
because of the success of those two if
there was any acting that didn't work
with young Barry or Elderberry the young
Choice doesn't get to grow and then the
eldest Choice doesn't get to sacrifice
himself to be this evil that is willing
to be it and then the Middlebury doesn't
get to physically sacrifice himself in
order to save the Multiverse because the
lessons learned from Elderberry it
doesn't work unless everything hits
exactly right and that's why I hate the
hate for this film is because there's so
much Nuance that isn't discussed that's
a genius series of Parables like that's
a lot and so and and I thought one of
the smart things that this may just be
the the comedian side of me is that I
appreciate a good callback and so seeing
who the the villain presence actually
was that it actually was a version of
Barry yeah I thought that was pretty
well handled and I was like okay I left
the theater like okay so we had Zod we
had the presence of Michael Shannon here
but we also had like we're kind of
fighting ourselves and given the movie
and how it played out with Barry's sort
of wrestling against what what do I do
do I say my mom do I just like let the
the multiverses be yeah I thought that
that was the perfect villain choice for
the third act and isn't every superhero
story really Manning itself and that's
the genius of this one yes it's
mannequin self times three it's man
against his own annoying self it's man
against the decision it's man against
his physical self it's literally the
ultimate hero's journey and I honestly
think it delivered on that more than
anyone's giving a credit for I think it
honestly Andy muschietti had the
impossible task of we talked about a
perfect storm marketing animation had to
film this movie over how many years and
put it together and change rewrites and
change Studios and change Executives
there's three different filmed endings
to this movie and it still doesn't feel
like five movies it feels like he made a
movie if this was a lesser director
which why I'm so excited for his Batman
he was able to make this out of paper
mache like there's so many pieces that
are like we're gonna glue it and see
what happens that's insane I don't put a
lot of stock in there you had six years
to make this movie this was like you
knew you had six years to do your
science project in fifth grade and then
the week before it was due the teachers
completely changed they said oh by the
way my kids you can't do the volcano
yeah
volcano and it's like I've been building
a volcano for the last five years now
you now I got to do the the Bunsen burnt
like this is something totally different
and that's actually one of the scenes
they cut Henry Cavill fighting a volcano
they show it more than things but that
is actually the thing is like you cut
the guy that is your marketing you cut
uh Henry Cavill from everything because
you don't want to confuse the audience
and then you make a great joke to make
the audience go like no no that's not
what's going forward and now the
audience goes wait is he gonna be our
new Batman I'm like no that was the
point of using him it's so interesting I
cannot imagine being Animusic and going
okay I'm gonna make this very strong
decision to ensure the audience is very
clear that this Multiverse is still a
problem and now half the articles I read
is like how George Clooney's gonna
impact Batman I'm like that's not the
thing that was a bit of a surprise for
me seeing it the second time because
when I saw it at cinema times they did
not have the post-credit scenes and so
seeing that I was like oh well this is
doing fun well let's finish hey look at
this but I what what impresses me about
this movie and I certainly have my
criticism but I actually think the
Tomato Meter score as of now 66 percent
I'm like that's right where I probably
would land with this film but what I
will say the impressive job this movie
did is being such a ride for the most
part where you to the point where I even
think it's to the detriment of a of an
actress like Sasha where it's like you
just didn't have enough time you got to
fight a lot you have enough time to
really show us because I I think that
that Supergirl was underserved in this
film but I love seeing how fast the
movie could move at points but then also
slow down not too slow with the flash
stuff but when we get that final goodbye
between Barry and his mom I thought that
emotionally really packed a while I
think there's so many scenes that are
that are akin to that that do better
than other movies trying for the same
thing I think that's definitely a
highlight but even the comedic elements
of explaining the Multiverse through
spaghetti which we're going to talk
about is genius but also the scene where
you discover the Multiverse by a name
drop about an in our universe Multiverse
joke like we talk about errors all the
time right like the Mandela effect and
Eric Stoltz are buddies like that joke
we're informed of the Multiverse and
then Landing that joke with a thigh
tattoo that's actually on a calf like
there's so much good humor in this that
like Marty mcthigh dumbest joke
it's such a bad girl the roommates got
me they that whole scene was slow and
trusted the audience to be like okay we
need to breathe a second it's like uh
when you're watching a horror movie and
there's a joke that makes you laugh just
to let your diaphragm like spasm a
little where you're like okay I needed
that like this
movie you have those moments like okay
we've been running a lot let me stop
running and that is the power of like
you know two Ezra's there a lot and they
know it so they let the audience go okay
I literally am exhausted from running
comedy comedy comedy but it serves the
narrative and it suits his comedy so
this movie never feels like I mean in
stand up you have so many different
types of comedians sometimes comedy
feels like five writers wrote it to me
this all felt like one type of Comedy
that served the movie and to be honest
and we've seen this in the MCU too
there's a lot of times when anytime
you're dealing with time travel or even
a Multiverse you're gonna get it back to
the future joke yeah and they work
better than others and so just it we're
the same if there's a big news story
every comic is going to have their angle
right I thought this angle on
referencing Back to the Future worked
pretty well and I'll also give a huge
shout to uh Sierra Monica Jackson from
dairy girls who is also one of Barry's
Pals uh is sort of in the roommate clip
yeah and what if she is just so so
fantastic for their comedic timing and
so it's just a great supporting role in
there but if you're talking about
support for the flesh we're looking for
anybody that can help us that he knows
from the Justice League Wonder Woman
ain't there Aquaman's not picking up the
phone who do we call okay Batman is
there a Batman in this universe there is
or at least there was and we don't
really know what's going on with bats
now so we show up to Wayne Manor and it
ain't Ben Affleck anymore we gotta see
at the beginning of the movie and now we
get Michael Keaton a very different
looking Batman than even he saw in 92
when we left him with Batman Returns
what the hell happened to Batman well
actually it's good news kids Gotham City
is clean it's safe you can take your
family there again and you won't get
murdered leaving the theater the problem
is Batman has just let himself go
there's no more Alfred taking care
apparently GrubHub does not deliver to
Wayne Manor he's still got to cook his
own spaghetti I love that in the comic
books they use Batman all the time
because it sells but I love in this
movie that using Batman actually feels
like a character motivation I I was so
afraid and itself and itself
but I was worried about that the whole
time but then if you actually look at
what Barry's journey is it's is it worth
losing everything to save my parents is
that not Batman's Journey what a great
pairing that doesn't always land that
well in the comics sometimes it's like
okay so flash is not doing sorry and I
was so worried the movie would feel like
it was just throw some bad but they did
such a good job with Michael Keaton and
his emotional vulnerability as Batman
being like you did the thing I always
wanted to do and like since he's Michael
Keaton it's so cool when he's like I
just put new I could land it and I love
that that translated with like two lines
of dialogue and then you've got him
being a recluse because of never
actually accomplishing the goal that he
set out to do he cleaned up Gotham it
didn't make him whole but then you
juxtaposed that with Ben Affleck who's
still an older grizzled Batman who
admits he's lonely and basically his
last line in this entire universe is
gonna be like maybe next time yeah he's
got this broken these duality of broken
men one who's accomplished the goal one
who hasn't but both can never feel whole
because of the thing that Barry did
accomplish that has to let go so it's
this beautiful triangle of just sorrow
and broken men who have to accept that
as the way life goes on and they each
teach themselves that lesson the same
way the three berries teach themselves
that lesson and in the same way that I
enjoy day drinking to Chicago's 25 or
six to four and meeting Michael Keaton
that way you still don't know what
you're getting with this Batman and so
it's like is this going to be like like
a sort of drunken Mentor is it gonna be
like a Doc Brown yeah are we actually
gonna get our hands dirty and just
seeing how much action 89 Batman got to
do I was thrilled it was one of the
highlights of the movie for me as a kid
who one of my first theater experiences
was seeing Batman in 1989 and we got to
see it with today's technology but I
also love that it didn't feel like that
Batman used today's technology I love
this I still had trouble turning the
neck with the flash Jokers yeah I also
love that they use the technology of
then as if he retired like five years
later like he retired 97. like I love
that he's still gonna be like what's
your weight not only is that a great
callback it shows he didn't improve much
stuff and it gives us a moment to be
like how's this Batman doing today and
then when he's fighting the Kryptonian I
love that's also a giant comic book
metaphor because he's literally fighting
a giant Batman's always been the
underdog so it's like the the Giants
versus your guy connection but if you
think about Batman the Mythos that
Snyder was able to do Batman's always
been distrustful of kryptonians how
fitting is it that a Kryptonian takes
out Batman and Batman wouldn't have had
Kryptonite in this universe because he
wouldn't have been prepared they always
said Batman can defeat anyone if he has
enough time to prepare Batman is like
Bill Belichick as a coach like if you
give him time to prepare he can figure
out how to scheme against your
quarterback but if you just show up to
play in a sand lot somewhere which
unfortunately for superheroes that's a
lot of their job is not being prepared
and having to just move on the Fly and
so it actually speaks to the cast of
this movie that you do need not just one
superhero maybe not just two or three
superheroes you need a whole Gaggle to
go fight whatever the Menace is and so
we adventure with Batman we realize okay
this guy's committed and I not like I
had any hesitancy this was 10 years ago
I might have walked into this movie
being like is this is going to be Keaton
or is he just kind of showing up for the
paycheck to say a couple lines that we
know and we'll clap and then we'll get
out of here but no that was Keaton
invested in this character in sort of
finishing the arc that I'll even put
Birdman in and then we meet Supergirl
and now we're off and we're all fighting
this the this this together and it was
that's when the movie started to just go
with such a Breakneck Pace that I was
enjoying all the action but I was also I
was missing some of the character stuff
sure from the first half of the film
until we got that grocery store scene I
agree and I do feel like Sasha Kaye did
absolutely everything she could with her
screen time but if there was one
character to give another scene too it's
her I think so much potential it was
kind of like how I felt about Ray Fisher
walking out of uh the Joss Whedon uh you
can see all the pieces you're like but I
want the puzzle exactly I want more from
that character I'm like I'm ready for
the Standalone yeah I think that she I
mean they're making a standalone
Supergirl movie it's intentionally in a
different universe but if any character
works imagine a Supergirl in the comics
that they're adapting Supergirl is
mourning the loss of kryptonite she's
mourning the loss of everything and she
was raised on an asteroid so it's a
great nurture versus nature story of
with Superman's raised by Mom and Pop
Kent the ultimate good this girl's
raised by herself and alone and she's
still good but she's Rough Around the
Edges but that S standing for Hope means
more to me with Supergirl than Superman
to be honest because Superman's got
every reason to love Humanity this girl
doesn't so I love the idea that
Supergirl is just inherently good and
that's even more powerful so what better
way to have a girl Lost in Space movie
that is woman of tomorrow than like I
lost my whole universe Barry messed
everything up I'm by myself and like I
just started liking humanity and now I'm
trapped in this position I would love to
see her get to be the full movie we all
felt and wanted because again she had to
fill in the giant shoes of Henry Cavill
first no one has had to be Superman yet
since Henry Cavill she had to be super
girl who less people identify with who
less people know and she had to be the
first person to Don the S since Cavill
in a movie that's referencing Cavalry oh
and by the way you're not going to be
the only super person that appears in
this movie because if you talk about
spoilers and you talk about cameos
Fourth of July is coming up it was like
the grand finale of a fireworks display
where you see George Reef holy crap then
Christopher Reeve Nick Cage making john
schnepp way up there in nerd Heaven
happy it was just like it was just
flying at you what did you think of all
these reveals and and previous Batman as
well I mean you know like we mentioned
George Clooney's credit scene did did it
work for you like a lot of people I
think who heard maybe Rumblings if this
could happen or were expecting some sort
of Cameo what their expectations were
were they met for court I feel like this
the time Dome psychodrome allowed the
visuals to work for me better because I
was already in that uncanny valley space
I think I would have preferred like Nick
Cage to just be in a filming studio and
have it just more than a cagey as
opposed to like a 2d 3D rendering of
Nick Cage because I think he physically
filmed but I wouldn't have known that
unless I read the trades like I wouldn't
have uh I would have felt like just as
real as George Reeves and I think part
of it was going okay we need George
Reeve to look as real as Nick Cage so we
had to make Nick Cage look less I think
they had to like kind of big glossy like
the old like oil on the lens I felt like
they had to oil the lens for all this
like mixed the difference around right
but I would have preferred if it was
just um you've literally got an
opportunity to have a different Universe
look differently and use different
mediums I would have had George Reeve
look more uncanny valley because of time
Chris free look a little bit more real
Nicholas Cage be physically him and I
would have had the more modern mirror
the idea of chronology and make it look
more real to our eyes I also would have
mixed in other mediums like Batman the
Animated Series that way your brain goes
oh right we're experiencing a Multiverse
this is why this looks like this oh by
the way let's put in some comic panels
because we could have a spinning Dome of
comic panels have an Infinite Crisis
comic panel spinning and then your brain
is just like okay it's stimuli I get it
and you will tell you why I'm thrilled
they didn't put Batman in the Animated
Series in there and that's what that
might be my favorite show it's like that
Monday Night Football might be my
favorite shows of all time but you you
would never be able to avoid comparisons
to into the spider-verse and across and
we do way too much of this any but I
think it's I think a Marvel DC comp is
warranted when we're talking about the
usage of a Multiverse setup and I feel
like Marvel's much more guilty of this
than DC is where you in at least live
action we'll say because I think across
the spider versus his best movie I have
or will see this year have you seen
Indiana Jones already Mission Impossible
the The Flash
across whatever's best movie I've seen
um but Marvel I think a lot of times
it's we're using the Multiverse as just
sort of an excuse to get some cameos
have some famous people in our movies
yeah and with this I didn't mind all of
those super people coming round at the
end simply because I feel like we earned
our way into this portal by watching
Barry and the struggle that that
character was going through you know and
and this is also somebody who's super
young who isn't fully aware of what
their powers are they have a mentor in
the same way that Spider-Man had a
mentor in doctor strange but whereas the
mentor for Flash Ben Affleck's Batman is
like you do not know what you're doing
nobody wants my parents back more than
me this is not going to go down how you
think whereas Spider-Man's Mentor is
like no I don't want to do it all right
fine I'll do it it's like dude really
really you're gonna that's what it is
this guy this kid wants his girlfriend
you're gonna like Risk the whole Mall it
just didn't I Stephen Strange might be
the best surgeon on the planet you ain't
operating on this brain nope I don't
trust you with that decision so I feel
like the Multiverse is actually used
better or time travel as well as used
better with this property than what I've
seen from Marvel I think it's the most
succinct I honestly think that
explanation of the spaghetti is the best
explanation I've ever heard for retro
causal Multiverse it helps that it's
Keaton doing I mean it definitely helps
because you're like tell me more read
the dictionary Michael like you're so
invested but also it's comedic in a way
that sometimes Marvel doesn't land where
he's like I thought this was the
cousin's dinner genius line because
they're using a food metaphor and it
ties into the metaphor of spaghetti
being about what family represents
because he thinks that he would equate
that to family subconsciously whereas
Elderberry would relate it consciously
because the tomato sauce whole movie's
about spaghetti and family it's like
Fast and Furious but instead of Corona
and spaghetti love it but I also really
like that the visual allows the audience
that even if the most linear concept of
just some things run parallel some
things intersect you've got a visual
that's Wiggly it's so perfect for what
multiversal ideas are with the way we
actually have time because having
chronological time doesn't work that's
why Marvel had to do the splitting
Theory that's why Loki had to re-explain
that's why spider-verse had to kind of
dabble in it but the way you have to and
that's why that's when I call Koi that's
what I'm like I mean I can't figure this
out with the with the neurons and the
synapses in this it just ain't gonna
work anymore so that's why I call you
we've proven that time is linear here on
our planet like if you go to a top of
the highest mountain and the lowest
trenches time is different it physically
moves differently as related to gravity
because equals c uh E equals m c squared
proved that time is relative just as
mass moves things different this will be
on the test to take notes so when you
have the gravity change the disparate
relation to time because time is
something that we experience relatively
like for example when you're a kid and
you're 10 years old and your summer
feels like it's forever because you've
only had 30 months of your life like
Batman in 1989 it was everywhere it was
ever it was the whole summer but if you
think about what your experience of time
is uh say you're 10 years old summer is
three months that means you've lived uh
what three 12 times 10 is 120. so you've
lived 120 months so for you three months
out of 120 is a market percentage of
your life by the time you're 30 a month
is nothing because relatively your
experience of time has changed so time
being relative is never addressed in
multiversal Impact correctly until this
movie because it has to be causally
affected on both sides everybody's
thinking the Charlie Day gift right now
what do you say to me threads did he
give us math no it's there is a sailing
point in there you reach into the into
the pudding and you pull out the red
flag like doubled there that is no this
is this is how time works and it works
for the story it's not just certainly
it's not just there for the science
nerds but it's also not there just for
fan service it's there to tell a story
so I guess my next question would be we
got a great ride with this the box
office results were nowhere near I think
what the studio was hoping for or
anticipating so where do we go from here
I think the credit you can give the
story in this movie is that it was a
nice clean slate if that's how James
Gunn and Peter saffron want to use it
going forward with now the DCU but
before we get there we have Blue Beetle
coming out we have a new Aquaman movie
coming out we have uh apparently George
Clooney back in Batman explains so start
with that post-credit scene sure and
then explain maybe where we could be
going based on this movie or was this
movie sort of In Your Eyes the close to
a very turbulent and sometimes highlight
packed chapter in the DC history I think
the box office kind of made at the end
uh I think that if people wanted the
continuation of this universe uh they
should have gone to it because I think
that this is now they they made a movie
that ended with a K can eat it too it
could have continued or it could have
closed and I think this closed it
because the ending the post-credits
scene allows for hey you're like this in
every Universe haha crazy drunk guy this
funny scene but it's basically to say
like we can keep Aquaman if you guys
should that's what that scene was I was
like that's the most Studio suit I've
ever been I was like this scene is
literally to save a lot of dialogue like
Jason Momoa can stay isn't it oh there
it is that's what that scene was so now
the idea is you know we have Aquaman
coming out the end of the year which I
don't know if it's going to do well
because Flash had way more Buzz than
Aquaman does and Flash had way better
reviews Tom Cruise was like jumping on a
couch like Oprah saying how good it was
that's not gonna happen Stephen King
loved it it had Buzz I'm not I'm not
gonna do that to Aquaman again though
because I wasn't sure what the first
Aquaman was going to do and then it ends
up doing a billion dollars and being
even more successful than the fictional
James Cameron Entourage genius I love
that so much and I love that James
Cameron is actually fighting the box
office past Aquaman at one point I love
that but I I think that now Aquaman
comes out I think maybe kind of
unceremoniously I don't know if Warner
Brothers is going to want to invest a
lot more into it I don't know if they're
going to want to throw a lot of money at
the Press store if this is the reaction
they've had at their prior work I think
Blue Beetle uh James Gunn has said is
the first DCU character and that
Superman is the first DCU film so I
think this character is going to
introduce the World by being very like
neutral I don't think they're going to
reference other things I think it's
going to be a contained Spider-Man
because we're still sleeping on Superman
until 2025. yeah so I think this is
going to be like hey this guy's here and
if it does well so she uh not so she um
uh solo gets to show up but if it
doesn't do well he doesn't so I think
that if you want Blue Beetle in the DCU
people need to show up I think Aquaman
is kind of a bygone not gonna happen
they've said that he's gonna stay but I
think they said that when they thought
that this movie is going to make half a
billion dollars so like I I think they
film that as like an either way I don't
think we see George Clooney again I
think that was for us I think that was
for just like there's I think that was
for him in the same way that Michael
Keaton got to come back and be the
Batman that you know we could have had
two or three or four more Batman movies
starring Michael Kate in the 90s if
everybody was on the same page right
with Clooney I think that that was just
him and he's a politics being Batman
like apparently he'll he'll give fans 20
bucks again if you say Hey you saw that
movie but I think that for him that was
also just like let me let me get on the
big screen one more time and just kind
of wink and not I thought the line
worked because the line is making fun of
him being Batman I love that the only
line
I'm George Clooney
and I'm Batman that's The Cameo it's
genius but I think that's why we're not
going to see him again because like it
wasn't meant to be like ah it was meant
to be like maybe that was end much more
of a post-credits scene along the lines
of like Captain America filming the
chair out to the school video versus
something just actually furthering the
story right
um what is the one if I had to pin it
down so let's say that we are just going
to take we look at the box office fans
speak with their wallets it just the
interest isn't there we got to sort of
reboot this thing in gun and saffron's
vision what are you gonna miss most
about the Snyder verse and then what
kind of led us to and through this movie
The Flash so including everything you
just got to see what are you gonna be
like I wish there's some way and maybe
there is that we could at least keep
that I love how James Gunn casts I think
he's one of the best that's one of his
biggest strengths is because his movies
don't work without exactly the right
cast so I think that's absolutely a
strength I think the DCU has also cast
incredibly well so I would love if I had
my infinite power if I had the gauntlet
I would have this
Universe it's a whole thing I'll teach
you that next time but I think if I had
the power I would keep this as an else
world and I would allow I want to see
Henry Cavill back I want to see bat
Fleck back I want to see Gal Gadot like
these casting choices have always meant
the world to me because though and I've
been very public even on this very
Channel I don't see Zack Snyder's
characters the same way I see the DC
Comic characters I don't have to that's
the point of an adaptation they are a
different take therefore I'm excited to
see James Gunn's new take because I
think he sees the characters more like I
do so I feel like you know selfishly I'm
gonna be like those are the way I've
read them that's how I know them but
that doesn't mean I don't want to see
more of these guys especially since the
way Zack Snyder sees them is like
there's always been the Marvel or gods
that walk amongst us and DC is always
gods that are above us trying to figure
out if we're worthy kind of idea he took
it to another level where it's like
those Gods might be pissed too like
those guys are like they're looking down
a little bit and there's commentaries on
rage there's commentaries on like
adjusting to your reality there's so
many beautiful metaphors in the Zack
Snyder's world but it only works because
the casting is like the sexiest people
ever born like Jason Momoa Ben Affleck
like these are Gods like they cast these
like in Brave Fisher is like an actual
quarterback looking like impossibly
capable Charisma incarnate they cast so
perfectly it's a shame we never got to
see them it's kind of like Andrew
Garfield I always wanted to see Andrew
Garfield the movie where they wrote
Spider-Man because Andrew Garfield is
Spider-Man but Studios kept writing
Spider-Man so I love that no way home we
finally got to see Andrew Garfield get
that Redemption I would love if one day
we get to see these characters again in
a way that feels like they're get to
fully embody them without their Studio
juggle without the things falling apart
without the it feels like the world
engine where they're like collapsing the
world around that zod's doing is
happening to them they're always like oh
we're dodging all this rubble and we're
just trying to act and I think they're
better than that and I think Zack
Snyder's better than that I mean usually
it usually infiltrates at the worst
moment when you're trying to promote the
movie 100 when you're trying to actually
sell this thing and it's interesting you
bring up Andrew Garfield because we've
been doing a new show that I I go out
with and do pretty much just interview
people on the street about movies one of
the things with spider verses I was like
who's your favorite Spider-Man a lot of
folks saying Andrew Garfield but one of
the one of the great joys of doing on
the street was we were asking folks
about the Flash in Las Vegas all right
these are not people like going to
cinemacon these are people hanging out
in Las Vegas on vacation and they said
well maybe I might want to go see it
there's a lot of comic book movie
options now and then I would ask what if
I told you Batman is also in the Flash
and they're like oh really then they got
interested and then I said what if I
told you Michael Keaton is back they're
like I now I want to go the advertising
as much as nerds like you and I enjoy
the Super Bowl commercial I think a lot
of people thought it was an actual like
potato chip
commercial because you also you have
like Wayne and Garth back you have like
office space Ferris buellers all these
movie properties use the Super Bowl and
add space to just be like hey remember
that buy soap yeah and I think that a
lot of folks saw that and they're like
oh that's cute Michael Keaton dressed up
for this commercial not realizing he's
actually not just making a cameo in the
movie like a lot of other people did but
actually a huge part of the story I that
I mean that's what I would do with this
is I would I would make it the non
Doritos commercial what I would do long
term is let James Gunn run this universe
10 years and build a True Justice League
Play the Marvel game have a 10-year plan
build your new universe as soon as we
hit that moment like we did with phase
three where it was like where can we go
from here have DC have pocket aces have
this universe ready have a Justice
League movie that you don't let the
people know you're making do as much of
it you can you're gonna find out they're
filming it but make a full-on Justice
League too with this cast and then do an
Infinite Crisis movie in 15 years
smashing these universes together that
way the Nostalgia we feel for Keaton
right now is how we feel for Gal Gadot
how we feel for Jason Momoa and you save
that and then you get your Earth one
Earth two at DC and that's James Gunn
he's gonna play the long game so let
James Gunn fully build his Universe
don't use any of the same cast members
don't do any of those things and then
once you've hit that fatigue point we're
like okay we've had dark side what do we
do like once we've hit that point you
bring these guys back in you got pocket
aces you have a crisis movie and then
you bring in the TV the elements they
didn't do you bring back Grant Gustin
you drop your wallet bring back Stephen
Amell you make the biggest movie of all
time because you keep a good
relationship of these people that
deserve that second chance that's what
I'd do uh the best part about Corey is
he brings his own coffee we don't have
to supply it but no I mean all these
ideas and this sounds like you're you're
building a 10-year plan I think a lot of
students would be like uh can we get
that guy from it was on the Rotten
Tomato in he comes with me yeah um I
pitched the Sony verse I think with Naz
now I'm picturing my DC verse Warner
Brothers you've got my number I'm just
coming in to be Clooney in a post credit
team that's all I need so uh thank you
so much for joining us can't wait to
have you back soon sooner rather than
later here on Rotten Tomatoes now it is
y'all's turn please comment and let us
know what did you think of the flash
what about that box office what do you
make of that who is your favorite
character what were the highlights and
the lowlights of The Flash for you for
me my name is Mark Ellis my new stand-up
special alive and well drops July 17th
everywhere special preview event July
7th in the meantime you can follow us
right here on Rotten Tomatoes YouTube
subscribe to get that Bell for the
alerts all that good stuff and until
next time for the whole gang here I'm
Mark Ellis saying thanks for tuning in
we'll see you next time
[Music]